I'm gonna eat someone long into anyone's
big thick fat ones I'm gonna eat some
worms it's a real song Timon and Pumba
used to eat bugs and they turned out
great everyone's had a bug fly in their
mouth before so this is no different
just think of it as like it's popcorn
it's popcorn it's popcorn Hakuna Matata
aftertaste is like a pistachio but like
oh that was a bad one oh the head came
off I could see myself like drunk just
eating this whole thing
it sounds like pretzel stakes this looks
like something that will give you a
tapeworm don't lick it
what are you doing Keith oh don't lick
the bug that's not the right way to eat
the bug girl we know that could be
peanut butter in the inside I dig this
tastes like a little bit like a snappy I
liked it but like if it was like gummy
and like not an actual room but it was
just like a gummy version and a sour and
it had like different colors I think I
would love it then we would much rather
have a plate of dead grasshoppers to the
plate of live grasshoppers that's for
damn sure
imagine if you just saw that jump at you
like Ray Krone tree this also tastes
like going to the vet is like that
stainless steel you animal sadness not
bad
bring it on over what you got scorpion
scorpions scorpions yo isn't this how
Steve Irwin died this little guy this
guy will hurt you oh I don't know gotta
eat the stinger yeah oh it's so hard to
eat mmm oh my god oh whoa no wow this is
not right oh I like it
it tasted like old sweat right Scorpion
King incoming I legitimately believe in
the future we're gonna have to eat bugs
so I won't do it then like then my
talents will be like I'm not survive but
right now I know we got some Cheetos
yeah I mean I guess at the end of the
day what's weirder eating insect larvae
or motion together different chicken
bits into dinosaur shapes